le poids des mots et le choc d'une photo
un sos formé par une chaîne humaine au
pied des tours de passy pour dire aux
autorités
il faut sauver le monument avant qu'il
ne soit trop tard
son propriétaire un japonais n'a
entrepris aucun travaux un classement
des tours en monuments historiques
pourrait changer la donne mais le
dossier traîne depuis quatre ans on se
dit quand même quatre ans c'est pas
c'est pas 4 mois on peut comprendre que
c'est compliqué on peut qu'on peut
comprendre qu'il ya tout un procédures
administratives derrière mais iliad est
certes un certain moment se demande
pourquoi il ya péril en la demeure
il ya totalement péril on apprend de
rentrer en château mais déjà de
l'extérieur peut vous apercevoir que
l'état de délabrement est déjà bien
avancé la forteresse de passy date du
14ème siècle et a joué un rôle durant la
guerre de cent ans elle était un verrou
sur la route des envahisseurs du pays
charitois un territoire très attaché à
ses vieilles pierres
ici on a aussi a vraiment de patrimoine
très intéressant qu'on laisse
malheureusement s'abîmer parce que le
propriétaire ne souhaite pas pour le tas
de raisons s'y investir mais pour le
coup moi je suis ravi de voir qui a
beaucoup d'habitants qui considèrent à
l'instar de ce qu'on a fait à la charité
que patrimoine c'est important et donc
oui il faut les soutenir je pense que
les élus auront à se mettre en soutien
des initiatives locales et cette
association qui défend le château pas si
les tours est très très active autour de
l'histoire de l'époque médiévale et sur
la défense du château voilà donc je suis
évidemment très solidaire de cette
magnifique tâche
la photo du sos sera adressée à la
direction régionale des affaires
culturelles qui doit statuer sur le sort
des tours de passy pour ses défenseurs
une autre manière de mener le combat